la façon de vivre d'être de partager le
quotidien
depuis la signature de la première
convention de l'anru en 2006 la ville de
trappes s'est transformée et accueilli
des nouveaux logements commerces et
quartier
treize ans plus tard elle revient avec
une centaine de collaborateurs pour
visiter et estimer les enjeux du secteur
on a plusieurs circuits tout le monde
verra pas tous les mêmes quartiers dont
on aura effectivement un temps de retour
sur qu'est-ce qu'on a perçu comme on a
apprécié ce qui a été déjà changé et ce
qui a pu être améliorée en termes de
cadre de vie quels sont les enjeux de ce
qui reste à faire est ce que chacun a
ressenti les choses de la même façon ou
pas confrontés choses donc on aura
attendait change ensuite sur cette
perception des projets qui se
construisent localement sur des dizaines
d'années pour un nouveau plan pour
l'aménagement paysager et l'implantation
d'équipements publics dans les quartiers
camus et barbus on va agir sur deux
secteurs urbains sur lequel on n'était
pas intervenus parce que il y a il ya
quinze ans maintenant
c'était pas c'était pas évident ce
n'était pas nécessaire aujourd'hui ça
l'est devenu pour deux raisons c'est que
le temps a passé et bien sûr est que le
bâtiment comme tout ça sa vie est
et puis et puis ça ne va plus avec tout
ce qui a été fait autour par rapport au
premier premier contrat ce c'est un
petit contrat c'est pas 2 c'est pas la
même ampleur pour la première convention
en rue
environ 350 millions d'euros ont été
déboursés pour le mpn heureux la
prochaine convention sera signée mi
octobre et représentera 1,5 million
d'euros d'investissement le plan
d'action de mise en oeuvre des travaux
qui a commencé en 2019 s'achèvera en
2024 et concernera aussi les quartiers
de la verrière et plaisir